plus loin avec gwen diva journaliste
indépendante bonjour à anor vous venez
de sortir cette année un seul livre
enquête la france en face aux éditions
fayard une plongée aux côtés des
français qu'on n'entend jamais et qu'on
risque à nouveau de ne pas entendre en
avril prochain annonce espère qu'on va
les entendre mais il ya du
mécontentement on l'entend un petit peu
et puis il ya aussi le fait d'aller
voter ou pas aller voter c'est une façon
de s'exprimer on va le voir ont en tout
cas c'est à suivre dans votre lit face à
vous gauthier rybinski la rédaction de
france 24 jean gauthier sommes nous à la
veille du à l'avant veille de l'invasion
russe de l'ukraine washington 16
d'alerté l'europe de temporiser et
moscou de souffler le chaud et le froid
pour exemple cette phrase sibylline de
sergueï lavrov aujourd'hui
nous mettons en garde contre des
conversations interminables sur la
résolution de problèmes qui doivent être
résolus aujourd'hui mais néanmoins en
tant que ministre des affaires
étrangères je dois dire qu'il y a
toujours une chance voilà du en même
temps un version russe sauf que dans la
foulée bien le ministre de la défense
aguicheur ghoul il s'est empressé
d'annoncer la fin de certaines
manoeuvres militaires à une faut-il y
voir le signe que les russes n'ont
finalement jamais eu l'intention
d'envahir l'ukraine ou bien qu'ils
jouent tout simplement avec nos nerfs
depuis le début je les intentions des
russes moi je ne connais pas personne ne
les connaît les américains semblent les
connaître mais ça fait deux mois qu'on
nous parle du nombre d'une attaque
imminente donc les russes y font du
chantage à la guerre tout simplement ça
s'appelle véritablement du chantage
quand on masse des centaines de milliers
d'hommes qui entoure un pays tout en ne
rentrant pas dans ce pays ne disant pas
qu'on va le faire de toute façon ça
serait quand même une grande première
que vladimir poutine il l'a jamais fait
né en géorgie ni pour la crimée il a
jamais dit à l'avancé ce qu'il allait
faire donc en tout cas si le but de
venir poutine c'est de nous faire peur
c'est réussi parce que de notre côté du
côté occidental on ne cesse d'exprimer
cette panique d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien la dizaine ski il a dit le
merveille nos ennemis c'est la panique
tout le monde panique tout le monde
panique en ukraine sa gêne quand même
beaucoup les ukrainiens le fait que les
américains panique à ce point donc on
est dans la gesticulation la
gesticulation politique géopolitique est
dit pratique botia vous avez vu une
inflexion dans les déclarations russes
aujourd'hui qu'ils s'envoient la laisser
la voie au dialogue où finalement il ya
rien de nouveau sous le soleil c'est
peut-être quelque chose de nouveau en ce
sens que c'est une manière pour les
russes de reprendre la main par rapport
à ce flot alarmiste que les américains
emploient ces derniers temps si les
américains emploient ce x floire la miss
est précisément poro essayer de montrer
que les russes ne peuvent être que des
fauteurs de troubles quand lavrov
s'exprime aujourd'hui en disant il ya
une chance pour la négociation là encore
c'est une manière pour le kremlin de
montrer que les méchants ce ne sont pas
eux et que ici il y adeux l'hystérie
puisque c'est le terme employé par
vladimir poutine elle est bien du côté
américain donc est ce que c'est une
façon de rattraper dans la rhétorique
guerrière une manière de rattraper le
volant deux autres se remettre à la
barre de ce de cette rhétorique pourquoi
pas ça n'en dit pas forcément plus sur
les intentions réelles mais c'est une
manière de ne pas être balloté par cette
rhétorique américaine dont anne lise et
à juste titre qu'elle gênait même les
ukrainiens en tout cas le dans le grand
jeu diplomatique c'est au tour de la
fiole sous le chancelier allemand d'être
à kiev aujourd'hui pour une mise en
garde adressée aux russes écouter lola
chose
les activités militaires de la russie à
la frontière ukrainienne ne sont pas
compréhensibles c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
motifs raisonnables pour un tel
déploiement militaire
nous attendons que la russie prenne des
mesures claires de désescalade
sur l'allemagne tous agression militaire
envers l'ukraine aurait de sérieuses
conséquences politiques et économiques
et géostratégiques pour la russe
à quoi peut bien servir le chancelier
allemand dans cette crise annie va de
toute façon c'est toujours bon de
continuer à négocier donc la folle si
fait ce qu'on attend de lui et qu'il a
un petit peu peut-être tardé à faire on
dit de lui qu'il a quand même des
lunettes russe olaf scholz et puis il a
été prendre conseil auprès d'angela
merkel avant de faire cette visite il a
commencé par l'ukraine et ensuite il ira
à moscou celle inverse de ce qu'a fait
le président emmanuel macron la semaine
dernière donc
olaf scholz il fait ce qu'il peut mais
une fois de plus ça ça ça contribue à
faire ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire à satisfaire finalement les
goths l'autoritarisme du président va
nuire poutine qui apparaît comme celui
que tout le monde va voir dont tout le
monde parle et à qui tout le monde
téléphone gauthier les allemands sont
prêts comme a pu l'être en gala merkel
en son temps à se mettre à dos les
russes
les russes commises et anne ont besoin
comme les américains d'ailleurs de ces
intermédiaires qui peuvent parler avec
celui qui de l'autre côté de la deûle à
des barbelés ou de la barricade c'était
le cas de en gala merkel qui de par son
histoire avait aussi y compris même de
par une certaine pratique et maîtrise de
la langue russe connaissait les rouages
où les rouages même affectif et
psychologique du fonctionnement de ceux
qui occupent le kremlin là c'est plus
compliqué d'abord parce qu'il est tout
récent olaf scholz donc il faut lui
laisser un peu de temps pau pour
s'acclimater et c'est même du feu pour
lui voilà voilà et c'est compliqué parce
qu'en plus évidemment les intérêts
allemands économique on les connaît et
puis de l'autre côté l'allemagne depuis
qu'elle est démocratique c'est-à-dire
depuis 49 n'a plus jamais menacé un pays
quel qu'il soit et que ce n'est pas
demain qu'elle le fera en plus des
slaves je rappelle quand même côté
allemand cet historique de du mal absolu
que les nazis ont causé aux slaves il
n'est pas question que les allemands en
face à nouveau donc c'est ça qui est
compliqué mais on se dit que s'il scholz
peut être encore un dernier maillon de
dialogue avec poutine et poutine a tout
intérêt à jouer aussi cette carte à dire
vous voyez quand les gens sont
raisonnables comme monsieur scholz bien
moi aussi je peux l'être donc il peut
servir un peu alors peut-être qu'on va
exagéré mais à une sorte de petit
télégraphiste un qui serait le va et
vient entre eux entre le kremlin mais
l'occident un monde pourtant pour
ajouter ce que gauthier vient dire c'est
que les allemands pensent disent que
jamais plus des armes allemandes ne
tueront des russes ça c'est les sons de
la seconde guerre mondiale donc
évidemment ça peut paraître un principe
à peu d'un autre temps mais c'est ce
principe auquel tient aujourd'hui olaf
scholz même s'il est critiqué pour ça et
qui crédibilise sa parole face à bastia
pour ça que l'allemagne et c'est presque
comique a envoyé comique entre guy
envoyer des casques voilà un des aux
ukrainiens mal à se défendre et non pas
des hommes non pas des arts devenir le
réclament face à cela les américains une
cesse d'alerter sur l'imminence au
contraire d'une invasion russe écouter
encore anthony blinken c'était
aujourd'hui même au micro de france 24
une agression dès cette semaine est tout
à fait possible quand on voit ce qui se
passe autour de l'ukraine avec le
déploiement des forces russes est ce que
le président bailly donne pourrait se
rendre en ukraine comme le demande le
président ukrainien c'est pour l'instant
le président est très engagé dans la
diplomatie il a parlé aujourd'hui avec
la présidente janine ce qu'il avait
parlé auparavant avec le président
poutine on retient toute hypothèse pour
avancer la diplomatie mais dans un
premier temps ça dépend entièrement de
la russie est-ce qu'ils vont poursuivre
un retrait des forces qui entourent
l'ukraine pour donner l'opportunité à la
diplomatie d'essayer de résoudre les
problèmes qui existent ou au contraire
est-ce qu'ils vont continuer a
non seulement maintenir mais accroître
leur leurs forces qui sont déployés
autour de le cadet puis agir avec une
agression aussitôt que cette semaine à
washington qui pour autant par loin du
pentagone pense que poutine n'a toujours
pas pris de décision mais en tout cas
s'en donne les moyens
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien leur dis chiche aux américains
ils invitent même joe biden à se rendre
à kiev pour dissuader les russes d'une
éventuelle offensive ça aurait de la
gueule comme on dit pour pour byron de
se rendre à kiev dans ces conditions
écoutez ça aurait de la gueule peut-être
enfin ce qui compte c'est quand même ce
qui va se passer sur le terrain ou pas
cc on a on n'est pas dans la surenchère
de qui fait enfin ça je trouve ça un
tout petit peu un tout petit peu des
joueurs posent la question c'est que ça
rappelle en gros mitterrand à sarajevo
en 92 jouit moment du siège un peut-être
mais les choses ont quand même changé
depuis et notamment dans les relations
internationales là on est face à un
homme vladimir poutine qui s'enferme
complètement dans son autoritarisme et
qui je le répète a massé des troupes
autour de l'ukraine y compris jusque
dans la bio russie puisque un exercice
conjoint etc etc en fait ils narguent
l'occident en dix ans voyez nous on est
prêts nos hommes sont prêts à aller
mourir en ukraine pas vous pas les
vôtres et en cela je ne sais pas s'il a
pas raison parce que nous le disons
aussi nous autres et les américains
l'ont dit qu' on ne seront pas prêts à
déployer des hommes pour aller mourir en
ukraine donc ça c'est le vrai bras de
fer qui est en train de se jouer
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui compte plus que
alors il ya la diplomatie il faut la
continuer mais ce chantage psychologique
ce chantage à la guerre pour le moment
c'est venir petit sans envahir qui est
une espèce de gagnant mais non
malheureusement les américains ils sont
réellement persuadé d'après-vous d'une
invasion gauthier alors un certain
nombre d'internautes nous le montre un
photos satellites à l'appui c'est
effectivement ce cette concentration
impression de forces russes et si tel
était le cas ils feraient quoi les
américains alors dans la mesure où il
est exclu d'intervenir militairement est
ce que justement cet alarmisme cette
dramatisation actuelle c'est une façon
de dire nous avons fait tout ce qu'il
était possible de faire à partir de
maintenant on peut plus rien et on
n'interviendra pas ou alors c'est un
moyen d'acclimater et d'accoutumée
l'opinion publique internationale ou
fait que peut-être il pourrait y avoir
hâte à voir sur n'est plus
raisonnablement le problème pour les
américains ces deux placé la barre très
haut pour que s'il y avait une
désescalade quelle qu'elle soit aussi
minime soit elle l'ouest l'occident
puisse dire voilà la victoire inespérée
nous l'avons arraché sur le fil et ça ça
serait et on passerait finalement la
question du cren par pertes et profits
ça pourrait être même le cas s'il y
avait une vision limitée par la russie
de l'ukraine on parle d'une basse à
cette région sécessionniste
et bien si ça ne se limiter à ça et que
ça s'arrête à ses frontières l'occident
pourrait dire on a évité le pire on à
éviter l'invasion et kiev attention la
prochaine fois tenez vous bien n'ayez
pas de revendication atlantiste parce
que la prochaine fois vladimir poutine
vous mangera tout cru et voilà et là on
aurait gagné là encore c'est toute une
espèce de 7 ans veut en fonction d'un
rapport de force à partir du moment où
l'on considère qu'elle est celui qui a
le moins perdu dans un jeu compliqué
rafales en un mot timothy garton ash un
grand politologue britannique vient de
2,2 le publié dans le guardian et jeu
complètement d'accord avec lui là on a
une grande différence c'est à dire que
poutine lui sait ce qu'il veut et nous
occidentaux on ne sait pas on s'est
beaucoup moins on est dans les
dissensions on est dans la confusion et
évidemment ça nous affaiblit évidemment
ça renforce symboliquement vladimir
poutine c'est dans ce contexte en tout
cas qu'on attend la décision que doivent
prendre les européens quant au maintien
ou non de leur présence au mali un
sommet entre l'union européenne et
l'union africaine doit se tenir en fin
de semaine à bruxelles la france
pourrait elle aussi gauthier est ramenée
à cette occasion à revoir sa présence au
mali oui alors là c'est une histoire
presque qui ressemble parfois du dépit
amoureux si ce n'est que les autorités
maliennes actuelle son revers vachard
des avancées mais c'est vrai que la
france dit vous voulez pas nous retenir
vous voulez plus nous bannour faire un
malheur c'est à dire que non seulement
on s'en va mais pour pas apparaître
comme étant les seuls en situation de
dépit on y va on s'en va avec tous les
européens et débrouillez-vous je pensais
à un autre mot débrouillez vous et vous
verrez bien avec vos amis russes comment
vous en sortez dessin la position de la
france qui n'arrive pas à comprendre et
c'est là qu'il faudrait creuser pourquoi
ces élites malienne qui a qu'elle soit
régulière où arrivait bien putsch soit
aussi antilles françaises et là il y a
manifestement au mali comme ailleurs à
travers l'animosité vis de la france
vis-à-vis de la france le moyen de
marquer une identité dont on ne sait
plus trop et dell à travers les
invasions de djihadistes à travers les
coups d'état et finalement le seul seul
point qui fédère c'est cette animosité à
la france et qui rappelle en plus les
grandes heures de l'indépendance de ces
pays donc des années 60 une junte en
tout cas qui en s'en prenant à la france
fait semble-t-il vibrer une corde auprès
d'une partie de la population malienne
dans ces conditions on y va la france
peut-elle encore rester au mali n'a
t'elle pas intérêt à se redéployer
ailleurs on évoque notamment le niger
je pense que la france doit absolument
réfléchir sagement à ce qu'elle doit
faire et qu'elle doit peut-être avant de
penser à un redéploiement hâtif
tirer les leçons de ces erreurs parce
que là quand même il me semble que dans
cette affaire du mali et des forces que
nous y avons déployé il y a eu des
erreurs d'analysé phénoménal qui ont été
commises depuis longtemps depuis le
début sous françois hollande et contre
l'état français a sous-estimé le niveau
de corruption le niveau de faillite de
l'état malien le niveau de confiance et
ça c'est grave c'est très grave parce
que je vais pas comparer mais quand même
avec les forces internationales
américaines en irak en afghanistan mais
les populations nous en veulent ensuite
quand on a raté ce qu'on devait faire
sur place et est ce qu'on n'est pas là
en ce moment au mali je ne sais pas ça
en approche en tout cas il faut essayer
de se remettre sur pied et on va voir
justement quelle décision sera prise
sans doute cette semaine et peut-être
une concordance d'ailleurs entre ces
deux événements ukraine mali ce sera à
voir merci en tout cas ni va d'avoir été
avec nous merci à gauthier rybinski